STEPHEN OSADETZ: From the printing
press to the mass production of books,
there's a long history of scholars
adapting to new technologies.
We're used to dealing with
change in the humanities.
In the last 40 or 50 years, the most
significant advance in our field
has been the digitization of books.
This is a wonderful benefit,
but it's also a challenge.
Given that you could have hundreds or
thousands of books available to you
in an instant, where do you even start?
CHRISTINE FERNSEBNER
ESLAO: What can we do
with books now that we couldn't before?
You can use tools from data science
to explore the record of human culture
in ways that just wouldn't
have been possible before.
Whether you're a student wanting
to expand your skill set,
a librarian supporting
new modes of research,
or a journalist who has just received
a massive cache of leaked emails,
this course will show
you how to draw insights
from thousands of documents at once.
COLE CRAWFORD: In this course,
you'll learned the fundamentals
of text analysis, a set of
techniques for manipulating
the written word that stand at the
core of the digital humanities.
You will learn how, with a
few simple lines of code,
to make use of the metadata and
zero in on what matters most.
CEILYN BOYD: Research data is evidence.
It's evidence that you will use to make
your case to the scientific community.
STEPHEN OSADETZ: By
the end of the course,
you'll be able to apply what
you learned to what interests
you most, whether that's contemporary
speeches, journalism, novels,
or even art objects, material from
across the human cultural record.